[Music]
over 11,000 feet above sea level in
Bhutan a mountain kingdom nestled in the
Himalayas a three-month World Wildlife
Fund mission has been taking place in an
effort to capture images of endangered
Bengal tigers
and the mission was a success
the WWF released the images today
marking global Tiger Day hoping to
highlight the need for better protection
of wildlife corridors these unprotected
corridors allow Tigers to travel and
move from one guarded area to another
you cannot have especially with Tiger
that have huge territory they need to
move around you cannot lock them in the
box even if this book is called National
Park they need to move to mate for
instance and for this you need to find a
way to secure this kind of trouble well
the total number of Tigers fell from
about 100,000 at the beginning of the
last century to about 3,200 and 2010
recent conservation efforts appear to be
working for the first time in about 100
years which is something you know the
curve is going in the other way so we
used to have 3200 and now we have almost
4,000 so we have almost 7 or 800 more
Tigers and we have 7 years ago just
beautiful creature unbelievable I'm very
glad to hear this news about the tiger
having a resurgence I didn't realize the
fall-off was that drastic in any case
happy global tiger that's right